oui ça peut être une machine à café le
bip du micro-ondre les pompiers enin ça
arrive que je suis en pleine
conversation et qu' a le pimpon et que
je dis oh ça fait do là dos là dos là
salut bienvenue dans ce nouvelle
interview à la table dans cet épisode je
reçois Paline et Pauline a la l'oreille
absolue si vous savez pas ce que c'est
bah on va le découvrir ensemble petite
précision quand même Pauline ne se pose
pas en tant que représentante de toutes
les personnes qui ont l'oreille absolue
elle va parler de sa relation à son
oreille à elle qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire dans le qu bien est-ce que c'est un
avantage ou un inconvénient découvrons
tout ça après Mozart Beethoven Jimmy
Hendrix Pauline parce que on dit deux
qu'ils avaient l'oreille absolue alors
on va parler avec toi de l'oreille
absolue juste avant de commencer que tu
nous expliques et qu'on parle de tout ça
en détail j'ai envie de faire un petit
test j'ai un piano sur le téléphone
j'appuie sur une
note ça c'est un mi non c'était une
blanche non mais c'est ça c'est un je
rigole en disant que c'était une blanche
mais c'était bien un mi ça ça rien que
ça moi ça m'impressionne évidemment
parce que j'ai l'impression que c'est
naturel de savoir reconnaître les
lettres qui sont écrites pour faire des
mots dans notre tête ça me paraît
beaucoup moins évident de transcrire en
fait un son en quelque chose
d'étiquetable et de reconnaissable et de
différenciable alors que tu as même pas
eu entendu un son je sais pas j'ai ce
fameux truc de on donne le là tu vois
avant mais tu vas nous parler de tout ça
qu'est-ce que c'est pour toi l'oreille
absolue qu'est-ce que ça veut dire alors
l'oreille absolue c'est le fait de
pouvoir reconnaître identifier une note
de musique sans avoir justement de
référence extérieure donc sans avoir
besoin qu'on nous donne une première
note ok donc ça ça c'est autre chose ça
porte c'est l'ORE relative ok donc il y
aurait l'oreille relative c'est-à-dire
on donne une note de référence on dit
c'est celle-ci et c'est ce son là et toi
après toi le commun des mortels doit
après se servir de cette base pour
savoir si c'est plus ou moins haut et
reconnaître la note c'est ça exactement
en fait les oreill relatif il se base
plus sur les intervalles entre les notes
donc les écarts entre de notes donc si
on leur joue ben M par exemple euh qu'on
leur joue et qu'on leur dit que c'est un
mi ouis et qu'on leur joue un une note
après un sol par exemple et ben grâce à
l'écart entre ces deux notes là ils
saont dire que c'est un sol OK et et
donc l'oreille absolu c'est le CRAN
juste un petit peu au-dessus c'est comme
si intérieurement en toi tu as toujours
une note de référence qui raisonne
quelque part aut de toi et tu es capable
de de faire cet écart sans y réfléchir
presque c'est ça ouais en gros quand
quand là tu m'as dit ami il se passe
quoi dans ton cerveau tu réfléchis tu
alors euh je sais que ça peut se
manifester de plusieurs manières
différentes moi dans mon cas j'entends
le mot dans ma tête ok oui j'entendsu mi
il y a un petit bonhomme qui te fait
c'est ami ouais c'est ça ouais c'est ça
moi j'entends les les mots en fait c'est
mon cerveau qui a associé je pense le le
mot de la note à la fréquence et je
pense il y a un truc qui se passe entre
les aires du langage les aires auditives
et tout ça mais je sais qu'il y a
d'autres personnes qui entendent enfin
qui ont une oreille absolue un peu
différente par exemple je sais qu'il y
en a qui ont le la dans l'oreille et du
coup quand on leur joue une note il
compare à celle-là qui est dans ah ce
que je disais en rigolant tout à l'heure
qu'ils ont une note une note de
référence dans l'oreille ils font
marcher leur oreill relative mais du
coup ça reste un peu absolu vu que c'est
bien sûr ils ont pas eu besoin de
support extérieur quoi voilà c'est ça et
puis je sais qu'il y en a aussi qui
quand ils entendent une note ils
arrivent à l'associer au début d'une
musique ou d'une chanson qui est connue
par exemple mi quelqu'un qui a ce type
d'oreille absolu là te diras c'est le
début de la lettre à ellise il reconnaît
directement que c'est la première note
et ce genre de personnes ils savent
direct chanter sur la bonne tonalité ce
qui est pas le cas de de tout le monde
même mon cas parfois je chante pas sur
la bonne tonalité je démarre sur une
autre note et tout donc voilà il y a
plein de manières de d'avoir l' reil
absolu la manière que tu décris de
comment ça se passe dans dans ta tête ça
me rappelle un petit peu notre
perception des couleurs c'estàdire que
moi quand je vois du vert je sais que
c'est du vert je saurais pas te décrire
pourquoi je sais que c'est du vert c'est
ça j'ai pas besoin d'une are couleur
donc peut-être il y a il y a il y a truc
qui se passe un petit peu pareil dans le
cerveau c'est c'est possible est-ce que
c'est pratique pour toi tu es tu es
étudiante en musique ou tu étais
étudiant en musique ou tu travaillais en
musique non je travaille pas dans la
musique j'ai fait une formation au
conservatoire pendant toute mon enfance
et mon adolescence là je suis partie
faire des études en orthophonie donc ça
pas de rapport mais je continue d'en
faire énormément à côté je fais plein
d'instruments je poste pas mal de trucs
sur les réseaux aussi ouais VO
dansophonie il a phony quand même oui à
quel moment de ta vie tu te rends compte
d'une que tu es capable de le faire et
de deux euh enfin de le faire de
reconnaître des notes comme ça et de
deux que c'est pas le cas de tout le
monde parce que je trouve que c'est deux
choses très différentes ben j'ai
toujours eu pas mal de facilité en
musique j'arrivais à reproduire très
facilement des mélodies mais au début
j'entendais pas le nom des notes c'était
just j'avais une bonne oreille euh au
bout d'un moment j'ai commencé à
entendre seulement les voyelles ok donc
o e I a o au lieu de doré mifol ce qui
était un peu le bazar parce que du coup
je confondais toutes celle qui qui avait
la même voy dos et sol là donc c'est un
peu un peu compliqué et puis après ça
s'est affiné j'ai commencé à entendre
les mots en entier et ça c'était
peut-être vers mes 8 10 ans que j'ai
commencé à entendre les mots je je me
pose une question et j'ai juste envie de
creuser un peu dans ce sens-là si ça a
jamais été fait est-ce que quand tu
entends une note est-ce que tu vois une
couleur ou est-ce que tu as un goût ou
est-ce que tu as une opinion sur cette
note ouais la synesthésie ouais euh non
pas du tout je crois que c'est un peu
différent pour enfin il me semble que la
synesthésie tu associe sans le vouloir
enin une couleur ou une image il y a une
similitude effectivement il y a il y a
plus de 180 formes de syynesthésie et je
pense encore une fois toi et moi on ENIT
pas sûr et c'est pas le but mais je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup de formes
d'oreill absolu quand même de nuances de
choses et du coup comme la cynesthésie
oui tu peux associer sans le vouloir une
couleur à un jour de la semaine ou un
chiffre ou une émotion un chiffre ou un
goût à une date tu vois ça ça s'impose à
toi et comme toi tu parlais que les les
le nom des notes c'était un peu imposé à
toi j'avais juste envie de de naviguer
dans ce terrain là mais tu t'y
intéressais du coup c'est peut-être oui
on me l'a beaucoup demandé sur les
réseaux c'est peut-être une forme de
cynesthésie j'ai pas trop creusé la
question mais enfin disons que c'est des
mots que j'ai associé volontairement
enfin c'est c'est une comment dire c'est
une norme un peu
les étié selon la norme voilà c'est ça
et tous les gens qui ont le r absolu
comme moi enfin qui entendent les notes
ils entendront les mêmes ouais oua ouais
ou céit intéressant de de savoir si si
tu entends un orchestre jouer s'il y a
une fausse note quelque part est-ce que
toi tu vas la ressentir l'entendre
directement c'est a quelque chose qui
qui est pas gracieux un peu comme un
chef d'orchestre est-ce que tu as cette
qualité là ou est-ce que non autant tu
peux te concentrer sur une note et
savoir laquelle c'est autant quand il y
a un orchestre tu tu es pas capable de
tout segmenter alors j'entendrai pas
forcément tous les instruments tout le
temps mais oui ça peut arriver que
j'entend les fausses notes c'est
d'ailleurs un des avantages de l'oreille
absolu on entend vraiment quand c'est
faux euh ouais
c'est un peu le le cadeau empoisonné
quand quand tu écoutes de la musique tu
arrives à te laisser transporter ou tu
l'analyses oui ben je l'analyse
involontairement enfin j'entends les
mots dans ma tête moi ça me dérange pas
mais je sais qu'il y a beaucoup d'ore
absolu qui arrivent pas du coup à
apprécier la musique parce qu'ils
entendent une voix dans leur tête est-ce
que par exemple tu es déjà allé voir un
concert ave des amis on te dit le groupe
est sympa et toi en entendant tu entends
que c'est vraiment très basique
techniquement et du coup tu arrives pas
à te mettre dans l'ambiance oui ça ça
peut arriver ou mais je pense y a pas
besoin d'avoir l'ORE absolu pour ça ENF
c'est juste par ça c'est plutôt par
rapport à la sensibilité musicale ou
connaissance c'est quoi le ton style
musical préféré et ben un peu tout mais
j'écoute un tout petit peu de
classique mais pas mal de pop de
chansons actuell de électro tout ça tu
sais que tu vas me casser une idée reçue
pour moi j' là do être à fond la musique
classiqueoui tout le monde pense ça je
sais pas pourquoi ça c'est rigolo benah
j'ai une formation classique enfin j'ai
appris en classique mais j'écoute pas
que ça
pas si mal qu'est-ce qu'ils ont dit tes
parents quand ils sont aperçus que tu
savais faire ça ils sont ils sont
impressionnés ils sont fiers ou ouais
mais ils sont pas étonnés enfin parce
que ta mère elle elle a dit c'est
bizarre c'est moi qui l'ai faite il y
avait pas ça au programme à la base non
dans dans ta famille c'est très musical
très musical alors mes parents ont fait
un peu de musique quand ils étaient
jeunes mais mes frères et sœurs on a été
au Conservatoire tous les trois on a été
mis dans la musique de nos 5 6 ans tous
les trois et on a tous l'oreil absolu à
différents niveaux ah oui ok ah il y aur
peut-être une part de génétique dedansou
et tes parents pas du tout et peut-être
ils ont pas été peut-être qu'ils ont pas
été sensibilisés à la musique aussi
jeune que vous l'avez été aussi oui
c'est ça dans les études justement il
parle de ça d'une d'une prédisposition
génétique qui pourrait exister par
rapport à l'oreille absolue mais il y
aurait aussi le fait de commencer la
musique très très tôt qui aiderait
beaucoup à la développer en fait plus tu
commences tôt plus tu as de chances de
la développ si tu as le gène de l' oui
en plus comme ton cerveau il se fait
encoder à ce moment-là les branchements
se font différemment c'est vraiment le
moment ça ça ça paraît logique
d'ailleurs les les neurosciences ont
montré que quand on écoute de la musique
aussi on active la zone du langage dans
notre cerveau donc a fort à parier que
ce soit pas incohérent que toi tu
entendes le le le le nom de la note si
ça s'est marié comme ça en fait ouais
c'est ça et puis depuis toute petite je
fait vraiment cette association parce
que dans les cours de solfèage on nous
demande de chanter des mélodies en
disant le nom des notes quand on joue
notre instrument on doit se dire les les
notes dans la tête et ben à raison de 1
heure par jour pendant plusieurs années
au bout d'un moment ça fait beaucoup de
ouais si tu es prédisposé à ça ouais
c'est ça l'association il se fait parce
que pour le coup dans le cerveau le son
il a deux impacts il a le il y a le le
traitement du son en lui-même et la
qualification du son qui a encore autre
chose et toi tu sais qualifier le son
que tu entends donc ça veà dire que via
tes prédispositions et quand faisait
faire au Conservatoire on t'a développé
ces deux parties là à l'extrême très
cool tu aimais bien le Conservatoire le
solfage tout ça ah Solf non personne ne
ça c'est ce qui me semble aussi non mais
par contre ouais les cours de Flut
c'était incroyable j'avais un super prof
qui justement mettait beaucoup plus
l'accent sur la musicalité que sur la
technique ça c'est important et puis
sinon le l'orchestre tout ça c'est
chouette c'est c'est un truc au
Conservatoire avec les les personnes
avec qui tu étais que tu mettais en
avant que tu caché ou c'était ok Pauline
elle de toute manière elle reconnait les
notes ben je sais pas pourquoi c'était
un peu tabou au Conservatoire l'oreil
absolu c'est un truc qu'on disait pas
trop quand on l'avait mon prof l'a
appris au bout de 10 ans de cours
qu'est-ce qu' me l'a demandé je dis oui
ah oui il avait un doute et
puis pas mais après les gens ont
globalement une très bonne oreille au
Conservatoire pas forcément absolu mais
après il y a pas mal d'oreill absolu au
Conservatoire quand même est-ce qu'on
est-ce qu'on peut travailler son oreille
absolue peut-être pas son oreille
relative oui j'im imagine je sais pas si
on peut obtenir en partant de rien
l'oreille absolu en la travaillant enfin
les études sont pas très claires sur ça
mais je sais qu'on peut l'améliorer
enfin comme je te disais moi au début
j'entendais que les voyelles à force de
faire de la musique beaucoup beaucoup
j'ai j'ai commencé à entendre les mots
en entier puis maintenant j'arrive à
identifier des accords entendre
plusieurs notes en même temps on joue un
accord de trois notes par exemple et toi
tu sais dire les trois notes qui dire
que c'est un accord de sol majeur ou
donc je pense que ça peut se travailler
et sinon il l'oreille relative et ce
travail et tu peux arriver un résultat
très proche de l'oreille absolu ok après
c'est Einstein qui disait un don non
travailler ça s'appelle une mauvaise
manie donc tu peux avoir peut-être l'ORE
absolu et juste faire le basique ou
décider évidemment d'aller plus loin oui
ça ça nous en fait il a aussi un énorme
cliché par rapport à l'oré absolu qui
enfin qui laisse penser qu'on est des
génies ou qu'on est des des surdoués
c'est ça et qu'on est surdoué en musique
et tout alors que pas du tout vraiment
si tu travailles pas trop d'instrument
l'or absolu ça sert pas à grandchose
ouis ouais tu as déjà vécu ça par
exemple tu fais un morceau un nouveau
morceau sur l'instrument et quelqu'un
qui dit bah pour quelqu'un qui a l'oreil
absolu pas terrible
alors oui je joue de plusieurs
instruments et récemment j'ai commencé
l'alto enfin je sais pas si tu vois
c'est un grand violon je suis hyper nul
vraiment hyper nul et là l'oreille
absolue elle me sert à disons à trouver
les notes à jouer à l'oreille et cetera
ce qui est pas mal et assez utile mais
ça me donne pas du tout les
connaissances sur la technique de
l'instrument sur
ça remplace pas le travail du tout oui
la la mémoire procédurale celle du geste
c'est ça mais tuas tu as ressenti une
pression une attente oui vis-à-vis des
instruments sous prétexte que tu avais
l'oreille absolue oui euh oui oui quand
même B on s'attend à ce qu'on soit hyper
doué dans tous les instrument moi on me
dit que si je joue autant d'instruments
c'est justement grâce à l'oreille
absolue c'est c'est désant parce que ça
minimise tes efforts en fait en réalité
ouais c'est ça ouais vraent que si tu
rates on est déçu et si tu réussis au
lieu de te féliciter on dit bah c'est
normal l'ORE absolue ça sacralise un peu
l'oril absolu aussi alors que c'est pas
un truc c'est pratique c'est hyper bien
quand tu es musicien mais c'est pas
c'est pas un truc de on peut avoir l'
absolu ne pas être virtuuse et
inversement quoi je comprends est-ce que
infin tu as l'impression d'avoir un
super pouvoir genre j'entends un truc
que les gens n'entendent pas en vrai oui
un
peu c'est génial ouais non c'est moi
j'adore entendre le nom des notes je
trouve ça trop marrant je sais qu'il y
en a ça les dérange un peu mais moi
j'aime ok ça c'est trop drôle bon
évidemment on va pas dire un enfant au
7e étage immeuble en feu vite Poline
reconn c'est un sol ouin là son criès
non effectivement c'est pas très très
utile dans la vie tous les jours mais en
musique c'est pas mal faire des
arrangements jouer à l'oreille ouais bah
ouais est-ce que c'est quand même relié
au sens du beau c'est-à-dire est-ce que
tu toi dans ta tête tu es capable de
composer un peu une mélodie et d'en
prendre note je je compose ma question
en te parlant mais je pense que la
réponse est oui du coup que tu arrives à
à fredonner un air et te dire ah ça
c'est pas mal seul là SICI là machin tu
t'amuses à faire ça h moi je compose pas
trop mais je fais des arrangements pas
mal je prends une musique actuelle et je
pose dessus ma flute mon a mes guitares
et donc là pour ça c'est hyper utile
parce que ça te donne quand même une
certaine intuition intuition au niveau
de la musique tu as pas besoin de
réfléchir aux notes tu as pas besoin de
chercher les notes de chercher celles
qui vont bien ensemble tu sais
directement donc ouais pour ça c'est
bien j'avais vu dans une de tes vidéos
que tu étais capable de reconnaître la
note que faisait un corbeau est-ce qu'il
y a d'autres éléments que tu entends
comme ça de de de façon musicale pas un
klaxon une machine à café oui ça peut
être vraiment tout et n'importe quoi bah
pas quelque chose qui fait juste un
bruit genre ça ça fait pas de notes faut
qu'on puisse la chanter enfin qu'elle
puisse raisonner en quelque sorte c'est
faut qu'il y a une fréquence mais oui ça
peut être une machine à café le bip du
micro-ondre les pompiers enfin ça arrive
que je suis en pleine conversation et
qu' a le pimpon et que je dise oh ça
fait do là dos là dos là c'est drôle
donc mais c'est assez aléatoire enfin
parfois j'entends pas trop le nom de la
note j'entends je peux entendre entre
deux notes parce que les objets peuvent
être faux entre guillemets ou don
tataata sa c fait qu'est-ce qu'elle est
fausse non c'est ça bah parce que enfin
moi mon oreille elle est accordé sur le
la 440 donc c'est le la de référence de
en musique de notre époque et mais tu
peux avoir quand même des fréquences
entre toutes ces notes là donc ça peut
il peut y avoir une note entre le la et
le la bémol ça peut être entre deux
notes donc là j'entends moins clairement
et quand c'est pile la bonne note
j'entends j'entends le mot tu peux
entendre faux c'est trop le quand quand
tu rencontres une personne qui parle
d'une manière un peu chantante est-ce
que tu arrives à aussi connaître un peu
sa tonalité et est-ce qu'on a une
tonalité d'ailleurs alors c'est une
super bonne question moi justement ça
fait partie de mon petit bug d'oreill
quand il y a des paroles j'entends plus
les notes du tout ok ok ça ça ça nettoie
la musique je pense c'est lié du coup au
a du langage enfin mon cerveau se
focalise que sur les paroles donc j'ai
une petite pause quand j'en j'écoute des
musiques avec des paroles je je
n'entends pas du tout les notes je suis
obligée de me concentrer très très fort
sur la mélodie de comparer à des notes
de l'instru et tout donc non j'entends
pas les notes même si ça chante dans une
langue que tu comprends pas ok oui donc
c'est bien le langage qui essaie
d'interpréter et déé quo c'est ça les
mots prennent le dessus complètement
mais si si quelqu'un a un accent un
petit peu fort un petit peu chantant
est-ce que tu vas entendre des notes
dans sa conversation non ça ça garde le
même processus le mot va prendre
toujours le dessus m fait rire que tu me
dises ah je connais un mec qui s'appelle
Jean-Jacques il parle en
sol
là on on parle de tout ce qui est un
petit peu amusant par rapport à ça on a
parlé encore une fois tu te présentes
pas comme la grande représentante de
l'oreille absolue mais on parle de ton
expérience et de ce qui se passe dans sa
tête dans ta tête ça c'est très
intéressant mais est-ce qu'il y a des
inconvénients à ça est-ce que j'en ai
pas listé parce que je je n'ai pas vécu
ce que tu as vécu mais je me dis est-ce
que est-ce qu'on peut avoir des
inconvénients de vie par rapport au fait
de d'entendre les notes et de voir
l'oreille absolue oui oui euh ben du
coup comme je te disais il y a des gens
qui supportent pas du tout d'entendre
les notes qui qui arrivent pas à
apprécier la musique du tout moi c'est
pas mon cas par contre du coup j'entends
quand c'est faux mon oreille peut me
faire mal quand je quand justement
l'orchestre est pas accordé en 440 ça
peut arriver par exemple il peut être en
415 Hz pour des musiques Baro donc moi
j'entends entre deux notes donc c'est
très très inconfortable après quand un
instrument joue faux c'est ça et je
pense aussi à une autre chose moi je
vais bientôt commencer le saxophone mon
nouveau nouvel objectif et en fait c'est
ent transpositeur c'està-dire que quand
il joue un un mi le MI du saxophone
c'est un sol pour moi c'estàd c'est un
instrument qui est qui est pas sur la
même base de note enfin jeurais pas trop
expliqué mais du coup je sais pas trop
comment je vais apprendre parce que si
j'apprends avec les doités enfin du MI
et que il y a un sol qui sort je vais ça
va être trop bizarre ça va être trop
bizarre donc je sais pas trop si je vais
apprendre à l'oreille si je vais j'ai
pas trop de stratégie pour ça donc pour
les instruments de transpositeur c'est
un peu compliqué toi ça va faire comme
si si tu mangeais un bout de chocolat et
tu avais le goût du chouffleur quoi
c'est chocolat pourtant je comprends pas
ex je comprends pas exactement ouais
transpositeur je connaissais pas du tout
ce principe de je fais une note mais
c'est une note qui sort mais on
considère que et d'ailleurs la note qui
sort
est considéré par le commun des mortels
comme étant la note que tu as joué ou la
note qui est sortie si tu fais un sol
oui et que toi tu me dis que c'est un mi
qui sort oui dans la partition on
considère que c'est un sol qu voilà
c'est ça mais après on sait que c'est un
instrument transpositeur enfin la
partition est un peu différente les
altérations sont différentes au départ
c'est un code différent et très étrange
ouais c'est la sorcellerie un petit peu
mais mais je crois qu'il y a des gens
justement qui ont l'oreille absolue mais
en décalé enfin pas avec la même
référence que moi donc un saxophoniste
peut avoir l'oreille absolue basé sur
les notes du saxophone et on entendra
pas la même chose donc siil joue un sol
sur son saxo pour lui ce sera bien un
sol qui sortira il l'URA édicté comme ça
en tout cas ok hyper intéressant il y a
des jours où tu aimerais ne pas avoir
l'oreil absolu d'ailleurs j'aimerais
bien voir juste que ça fait de pas juste
de le mettre sur offre pour expérimentou
juste pour voir mais sinon moi ça me
dérange pas du tout j'adore j'ai
l'impression de beaucoup mieux
comprendre la musique de pouvoir sûr je
sais pas moi je j'adore moi je pense que
que que nous autres qui ne l'avons pas
on écoute la musique comme on comme on
écouterit quelqu'un qu'on rencontre d'un
autre pays qui parle pas la même langue
tu vois mais la personne serait très
sympathique donc on pourrait apprécier
ce moment d'échange mais quand la
personne pas si on essayait de
comprendre précisément on entendrait bla
bla bla bla bla bla tu vois je pense que
c'est un peu çaoi peut-être ouais
qu'est-ce que tu aimes le plus dans le
fait d'avoir l'ORE absolu ça de de de TR
relier à la musique euh ça et puis les
facilités que ça peut donner pour Ben
l'arrangement pour jouer à l'oreille
pour reproduire une mélodie que que
j'entends alors ça nous donne pas du
tout la mémoire absolue he parce qu'on
voit souvent des vidéos où on fait
écouter une musique de 2 minutes à un
pianiste si te la refait direct après
euh enfin faut avoir enfin l'oreille
absolu ça aide pour ça mais il faut
aussi avoir une bête de mémoire c'est
comme si on te lisait un texte de TR
tris pages et que tu devais le répéter
directementend tous les mots je
comprends mais tu peux pas forcément
ouais je comprends mais c'est
intéressant oui de le préciser ça par id
ou vraiment ou ou tu as écouté le
morceau il y a 2 secondes tu peux quand
même ref tu entends les notes non faut
que j'apprenne à le faire quand même et
que je le retienne surtout c'est ça faut
retenir quand quand quand tu écoutes par
contre un un morceau où il y a pas de
parole tu vas le décortiquer malgré toi
ou juste tu vas entendre les notes et
puis c'est tout ou ou tout de suite tu
rentres un peu dans l'analyse du morceau
non je rentre pas dans l'analyse juste
les notes viennent à mes oreilles comme
ça ououi c'est pas volontaire est-ce que
ça t'est déjà arrivé de te tromper ou
que tu te remettes en question sur le
fait que tu es ou pas l'oreille absolue
est-ce qu'on t'a déjà poussé làdedans ou
est-ce que tu t'es auto poussé dans ce
gros doute euh oui enin ça m'arrive
d'avoir des petits bug de demi-ton ok
c'est rare parce que en gros donc il y a
12 notes 12 notes si tu vois le piano
donc tu as toutes les touches blanches
et pu tu as aussi les touches noires en
fait les touches noires c'est donc les
touches blanches c'est dor ol ass et les
touches noires ce sont elles ont aussi
ces nomsl dorimifasol mais avec soit di
soit ben c'est ça donc c'est entre de
notes donc déjà les touches noires
peuent avoir deux noms oui sol Jaz la
bémol c'est la parce que oui c'est ça
dépend si on regarde en avant en arrière
voilà c'est ça et en fait ben justement
dans mon apprentissage j'ai quand je
chantais les notes dans ma tête ou que
je les pendant que je jouais de mon
instrument je me disais pas les dièes et
les bémoles je disais juste dos parce
que ça une seu
et pour les bends juste le dos sol et
juste je sens que c'est plus haut plus
bas et cetera mais du coup ça peut me
faire avoir des petits bugs je peux
entendre le MI dire que c'est un si mais
c'est un ouais et du coup tu tu tu as
déjà douté d'avoir l'oreille absolu on t
pas d'avoir l'oreille absolu mais c'est
jamais très agréable de bugger mais ça
arrive ça devient défi personnel après y
a un truc comme ça fait tellement partie
de toi que il y a un petit truc un peu
humiliant si tu tu te trompes et que ça
t'agace ou ça non en vrai je sais que ça
arrive c'est pas grave non et tu as déjà
lu la déception dans les yeux d'une
personne de ah non mais les gens ils
sont cont j'ai claqué des doigts a pas
trouvé la note non les gens ils sont
contents quand je trouve pas OK ou ou ok
c'est un peu comme le magicien qui qui
rate son t de magie on sait qu'il est
très bon mais ça fait
plaisir c'est bien en vrai aussi de voir
ça parce que le terme absolu je trouve
c'est très il est puissant ouais ça fait
très génie ou infaillible et tout ça
on est des humains on n pas des robots
et ça arrive qu'on des bugs ah mais
c'est important de de parler de ça c'est
c'est quoi d'ailleurs le le le regard
que portent les musiciens sur ceux qui
ont l'oreille absolue c'est bienveillant
il s'en fichent ou c'est un peu critique
ça dépend des musiciens je pense il peut
y avoir pas mal d'envie par rapport à ça
parce que quand tu as pas l'oré absolu
faut vraiment travailler beaucoupcoup
beaucoup et ces gens-là ils ont
tellement de mérite enfin beaucoup plus
que que moi euh mais oui du coup du coup
forcément il y il y a des musiciens ça
les arrangerait vraiment de l'avoir mais
c'est pas indispensable du tout on peut
très très bien des super musicien sans
avoir l'oré absolu et avoir l'oré absolu
et pas être des super musiciens je sais
pas je pense ça doit dépendre des
personnes ouais ah je vouis je voulais
te te parler de ça c'est moins sympa
mais moi je je t'avais découvert à la
base avec l'interview que tu avais fait
sur combiné qui était une très bonne
interview et je me suis aperçu qu'après
tu avais eu beaucoup de commentaires et
de message négatifs quand elle a été
diffusé les jiss d'Internet euh je je je
voulais savoir alors non pas comment tu
l'as vécu parce que personne vit ça bien
évidemment euh mais comment tuexpliques
de telles réaction parce que je me suis
dit j'ai r regardé après la vidéo je me
suis qu'est-ce qu'on a à dire de de de
de pas bon sur cette personne quoi tu
vois comment est-ce que toi tu as essayé
d'introspecter en te disant c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'ils m'ont dit ça ou
oui j'essaie de
comprendre bon je me suis d'abord dit
bon c'est
Twitter ça arrive généralement il suffit
d'êre une meuf ou enfin il suffit de pas
grand chose après c'est vrai que le
sujet était tellement pas polémique que
j'avais du mal à comprendre pouri ça
c'était pas clivant de base quoi c'est
ça et puis j'avais fait attention de
bien préciser que je parlais dans mon
cas que ça faisait pas de nous des
géniees que enfin j'essayais vraiment de
déconstruire ça après c'est vrai que
l'interview étaé assez courte et
condensée donc peut-être que il y a pas
eu assez d'infos je sais pas trop et
c'est peut-être aussi ce terme d'absolu
qui fait très qui peut faire un peu pom
peeu voilà et puis on m'a beaucoup dit
aussi que si je l'avais c'était parce
que papa maman m'avait inscrit à la
musique à 4 ans et que du coup en gros
tous les gens qui étaient exposés à la
musique pouvaient la développer que
juste j'avais de la chance d'avoir eu
accès ce qui est vrai en soi mais ça
suffit pas vraiment quoi ah non et puis
ça ça c'est un peu hors sujet en vrai
c'est un petit peu h débat quoi et ça va
tu l'as digéré depuis oui là ça va non
c'était pas facile sur le coup parce que
une V de ne s jamais très agréable on
était on était proche du harcèlement là
ouais un peu mais bon c'est une vague ça
passe quoi donc oui ben après la meut se
jette
quel' sur un autre sujet malheureusement
c'est comme ça mais j'en suis bien
désolé que tu vécu ça et et c'est
important aussi parce que c'est cool
qu'il y ait des personnes comme toi qui
témoignent de tous les sujets tu vois ce
que je veux dire là on parle on parle
pas d'une maladie on parle pas d'un
trouble on parle d'une particularité qui
est un peu méconnue on a la chance
d'avoir quelqu'un qui ouvre un peu les
portes de son cerveau pour dire voilà ce
qui se passe dans ma tête et c'est cool
d'avoir ces témoignage donc merci encore
désolé que tu es merci que tu es vécu ça
est-ce queil y a des choses dont je
te'urais pas parler dont tu aurais aimé
parler parce que tu sais je prépare une
interview sur un sujet que je connais
pas que je ne vis pas et peut-être il y
a des endroits des bouts de chemins sur
lesquels je suis pas aller ou taurais
aimé m'emmener je penseon a à peu près
tout dit on a fait le tour j'avais fait
la préparation absolue merci beaucoup
[Musique]
merci